[Music]
foreign good evening time for the Press
preview it's our first look at
tomorrow's front pages and we're going
to have a look at the headlines tonight
with the Guardians political edits of
paper Carrera and the telegraphs
associate editor for politics
Christopher hope they're going to be
with us from now until just before
midnight very good evening to both of
you uh let's have a look down at some of
those front pages certainly the ones
that we've got in according to the eye
following president zielinski's visit to
Checkers today the UK is expected to
back Ukraine's application to join NATO
the Metro has news of the Home Secretary
swella bravaman's speech today in which
she insisted that net migration to the
UK has risen to a level that's too high
and that there's more the Prime Minister
can do about it
let's bring in the express for you noted
no home secretary's suggestion that
white people shouldn't feel guilt over
Britain's past links to slavery
according to the guardian MP is loyal to
Rishi sunak have told Mrs Braverman to
stop trying to get to number 10 and
focus on her own job
whilst the telegraph reports that the
home office has privately predicted a
further sharp rise in Immigration by the
next election
the times carries figures projecting
that a fifth of all taxpayers will soon
be paying 40 Pence per pound of their
earnings
the guardian hears from cabinet minister
Michael Gove who believes Labor's
proposal to give the vote to 16 year
olds is an attempt to rig future
elections in their favor
is your ft reporting that turkey's
president looks poised to extend his
lengthy stay in power in the forthcoming
runoff election and The Mirror Has the
story of a British man who claims he
killed his wife out of a sense of Mercy
because she had cancer
don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen join the Press
preview have a look at the front pages
as we are discussing them and to do that
uh Christopher hope and Pippa Carrera
lovely to have you with us this evening
lots to discuss lots of different front
pages actually
um Pippa why don't we start with the
front of the Metro I had to read this
twice um to get it but I see what
they're doing as well as picking Time
Bomb a tough few days really for the
Prime Minister these comments today from
swella bravaman over the weekend pretty
Patel saying he is potentially managing
the decline of the party
yeah it's really interesting there's
been a couple of big conferences over
the last few days uh one over the
weekend the one you mentioned was a
conservative Grassroots
organization which uh ostensibly is
about restoring power to the the party's
Grassroots obviously lots of members
feel that uh Rishi sunx anointment the
vote never went to the membership means
that uh his mandate as Tory leader is
questionable
um and then of course today the
beginning of the national conservative
conference where we saw uh both the Home
Secretary and Jacoby smog as well as
other leading figures of the right mixed
speeches and so Ella bravamans is the
one that's been picked up by lots of the
papers this evening because it's uh
although we wish you sinek himself has
signed off the speech and the dining
Street said that they'd signed off the
speech and they were aware that she was
doing it it does seem to suggest it does
sound very much like she's suggesting
the Prime Minister should go further and
it sounded very much like to people in
the room and conservative MPS back at
Westminster that she was setting out a
leadership ship and Leadership pitch but
it comes down to these promises over
immigration the conservatives were
elected in 2019 with pledged to reduce
overall migration and we're anticipating
the next I think it's the end of next
week figures which are um due to suggest
that um it's gone up overall net
migration from 500 000 last year to
anywhere between 700 and 800 000 this
year
um which is is obviously the absolute
opposite of what they promised to do and
raises all sorts of questions about
um what internal Rises are going on
about for example student numbers about
skilled migrants and thresholds for
which you classify them
um the the shortages that that
definitely exist in sectors across the
UK
um and in
um uh different sectors across the UK
and whether they should need to be
filled by a skilled UK Workforce which
obviously the skill Gap is is there at
the moment or whether they should be
allowing more skilled workers in from
overseas so there's lots of thorny
issues
um behind the headlines
um but It ultimately comes down to the
promises that government's made or
migration which they're so far failing
to deliver yeah they were promising to
get it down to tens of thousands weren't
they and in your paper Christopher the
the headline there talking about that
sharp rise that Pippa mentioned
it's going to go up um and up and do you
think the government has been too
focused on on the small boats issue and
perhaps not on what this is which is
very much the legal route to coming to
the UK
yeah I've long thought and I've written
in in way where I write the telegraph
why is everyone ignoring the elephant in
the room which is the huge increase in
net migration 503 000 last year as Pippa
says there towards 800 000 in the most
recent 12-month period and we're
worrying about 40 000 or 50 000 people
coming off coming illegally across the
channel That so that's almost a symptom
for many about this lack of control over
net migration I interviewed sweller
braveman on my my podcast the Party
Conference last October she said then
that she would love to bring down
numbers to tens of thousands net that
was a figure of course which David
Cameron
um uh adopted in 2010 and that really
they never got anywhere near that and
that in fact that drove the debate
pre-brexit into why many people voted to
leave
um I think this this National
conservativism Conference uh over the
next uh is tomorrow and Wednesday as
well and also the one on on the on
Saturday the conservative Democratic
organization and these show to me that
there's a problem at the heart of
Richardson acts government in we don't
really know what he believes in some
areas people are waiting for him to set
out the kind of sunac vision to give
people hope because all these
conferences are coming after the
shocking defeat that over a thousand
seats lost in local elections Tories
want to feel there's some idea some big
idea to get the vote out of the election
now just 18 months away and they haven't
got one yet from Mr sunac all we have is
five Ambitions which are which are
hardly gonna set the Heather a light so
I think in the absence of any vision
from the PM you've got ministers
freelancing you've got sweller braveman
there talking about fruit Pickers
um of course that's because there's a
big Summit on food overnight and
tomorrow in number 10 dietary to deal
with the 19 increase inflation in food
but there's a feeling I think amongst
tours I speak to is where is where are
the sunny up plans now and many might
think there are no Sonya plans because
of brexit because of covid and the cost
of living crisis in the war in Ukraine
but despite that where is the Hope and
that's what everyone's missing and hence
you have MPS ministers trying to fill
that Gap with their thoughts yeah I
suppose The Hope perhaps is it's sort of
inflation coming down by the end of the
year but that's still some way off isn't
it and let's have a look at the front of
your paper Pippa in fact your story
um the Tory MPS tell Braverman quit the
PM pitch and stick to the day job
referring to the speech she gave because
it was a very personal speech wasn't it
it she talked a lot about her backstory
and it did almost sound like a the sort
of
um a speech that a potential leader
would give on on a campaign Trail
very much so and it was her own
backstory it was her political
philosophy it was her blue purpose her
personal blueprint for um for really
sort of you know the broader culture
issues cultural issues that the country
faces and it did feel very much like um
a pitch for the leadership after
um uh after the next election and it
kind of reflects I think um the fear
there's a lot of conservative MPS have
that the very best they could hoped for
um in the week of the Michigan Express
electoral test the local election
results which Chris just mentioned
um is to is to deprive Libra of a
majority but they didn't see a path to
uh winning a majority themselves now of
course this is all with the caveat that
an election is likely to be 18 months
away and so much can change so fast as
we've seen since last election in 2019
but as things are going at the moment
there clearly isn't an appetite despite
the sort of despondency that surrounds
many conservative MPS at the moment the
clear reasons appetite for Rebellion
um and uh but but that but that
despondent atmosphere doesn't mean that
people are happy with the way things are
going
um the vast majority of territory MPS I
think understand that it would be
absolute electoral suicide to try and
ice sunak and bring someone else in but
that doesn't stop a few on the right who
clearly aren't happy with the direction
of travel as Chris said even beyond the
right
um there's a large number of
conservative MPS feel that Russia neck
is lacking that Vision that excitement
that energy that's needed to take them
into to electoral Victory and he tried
tonight
um to well it was technically a um a
party to celebrate the king's coronation
in the dining Street Garden but they
invited uh 250 or so conservative MPS to
dining Street uh in my mind to shore up
that support to calm some of the nerves
to maybe try and prevent any sort of
potential
um Embers of a of a mutiny which might
end up flaring up into a you know the
full fire of rebellion
um and you know there's plenty for the
the touring piece to get stuck into with
election results there was the EU
withdrawal legislation last week which
many of them are very sorry the EU
legislation the bills um which the many
Tory MPS were very unhappy about and it
feels really like the party's kind of
like drifting a little bit and so on a
Brotherman here as we say in the
guardian has clearly
um spotted an opportunity just to sort
of you know remind everybody that she's
there and she could be the flag bearer
of the right but um in doing so his
language quite a lot of her I've heard
about them about her fellow MPS one of
whom told us um earlier that Rishi needs
to make it clear to her that she's
either a team player or a back venture
oh interesting okay I want to move on to
Ukraine uh quickly before the break uh
Chris front of the uh ft also front of
the eye as well in fact lots of papers
showing uh pictures of zelenski and
sunac together walk you away from that
helicopter or indeed hugging at one
point um we're giving them new attack
drones air defense missiles as well but
they're still pleading for jets
yeah and and and no Jets Falls coming
but it is Hardware it's missiles and
arrests that's throwing it on the eye
you mentioned is fascinating that is the
first indication there that the UK is
going to publicly come out and maybe
support Ukraine during NATO that is not
where we are at the moment in politics
um if that becomes confirmed tomorrow or
this week then that would that is that
shows soon after me being Bolder maybe
following a bit like what Boris Johnson
might have done if he'd been still prime
minister because he of course led the
West in in building the Coalition
against Russia after the after the
invasion of Ukraine I wonder whether
that's where it's going because it looks
um the readout didn't quite go as far as
the eye is saying there but they are in
saying today tonight that the UK might
support Ukraine joining NATO and that is
a big moment I think in in this war yeah
because Pippa most um NATO members
haven't publicly come out and said that
even if they believe it
yeah I mean it's an important caveat
here is that um that the membership of
Ukraine finito when the war with Russia
has ended but regardless of it like a
red flag to a ball even suggesting it
um reflector even suggesting it now
um and potentially uh we'll sort of add
to the paranoia that already exists in
Moscow about uh both the west and
specifically NATO's intentions when it
comes to Ukraine